Bene, buonasera. Dunque, il tema di questa sera è, forse, fra tutti quelli che toccheremo
qui, in queste tre serate, è quello più conosciuto. Tutti abbiamo in mente, credo, questa immagine
che associamo al Medioevo dello ius primen octis. E quindi, mi smentisco, l'abbiamo
tutti in mente, ma diciamo comunque che cos'è. Il diritto del signore del villaggio di avere
la verginità di tutte le ragazze del villaggio, o perlomeno tutte quelle non nobili, tutte
le serve le contadine, in particolare in occasione del loro matrimonio, andare a letto con loro
prima del marito, nella prima notte di nozze. Questa immagine è diffusissima nella percezione
che oggi si ha del Medioevo. Tant'è vero che la ritroviamo continuamente ogni volta che
c'è un romanzo storico o un film ambientato nel Medioevo. Magari ogni volta è dir troppo,
ma continuamente la ritroviamo. Vi faccio un paio di esempi per richiamare cose che
a molti saranno già familiari. Potrei farne tantissimi, facciamone due. Uno per quanto
riguarda il romanzo storico. Qualche anno fa, nel 2006, credo, è uscito un romanzo storico
che ha avuto un immenso successo di un autore spagnolo che si chiama Il defonso falcones.
Il romanzo si chiama La cattedrale del mare. È una gran storia ambientata nel Medioevo,
nella Catalogna del Trecento, una storia di lotta per la libertà e contro i soprusi, e si apre
con una grande scena che è tutta incentrata sullo ius primen octis. Voi sapete che un romanzo
storico, come ogni romanzo d'appendice, deve cominciare con una scena forte. Ci deve essere
qualcosa che catturi immediatamente il lettore. Se c'è un morto, meglio. Ma se no, comunque
qualche cosa di molto forte. La cattedrale del mare si apre con questa scena violentissima
dello ius primen octis. C'è un matrimonio contadino. C'è il contadino che si deve sposare
e sono contadini agiati, gente che lavora, che sta bene, rispettabile. C'è il banchetto
di nozze in campagna. E a un certo punto all'improvviso capita lì il Signore, a cavallo, accompagnato
dai suoi sgherri. E tutti sono molto spaventati che sia arrivato lì il Signore, però ovviamente
non possono far niente, lo invitano a sedersi. E il Signore si siede a tavola con gli altri
invitati e comincia a bere. E si accorge che la sposa è una bella donna e vuole che sia
lei a versargli il vino, la costringe a venire lì, la tocca. E poi quando ha ben bevuto il
Signore salta su, prende la sposa per un polso, chiama lo sposo e gli dice in virtù del diritto
che mi spetta come tuo Signore, ho deciso di giacere con tua moglie nella vostra prima
notte di nozze. Dopodiché trascina dentro la donna, poi esce dopo un po' abbottonandosi
i calzoni e dice al marito dai adesso tocca a te. E nessuno ha mosso un dito. Sono tutti
costernati, agghiacciati da quello che sta succedendo, ma nessuno di quei contadini muove
un dito perché il Signore ha il diritto di fare quello che sta facendo. Poi questo
Ius Primen Octis, così violento che in realtà è uno stupro, avrà conseguenze enormi. Tutto
il romanzo parte da lì. Tanto per dire che lo Ius Primen Octis è un formidabile pretesto
narrativo, mette in movimento tutta una macchina, c'è il cattivo, ci sono i buoni che hanno
subito il sopruso, c'è la ragazza che impazzisce dopo questa violenza. E il marito poi dopo
un po' parte dal villaggio e va a stare in città dove almeno c'è la libertà e dove
non ci sono i signori a cui bisogna ubbidire. Vi faccio ancora anche un altro esempio, sarà
superfluo anche questo, pazienza, un film che in tanti abbiamo visto, Brave Heart di Mel
Gibson, grande filmone medievale, la storia della ribellione degli scozzesi sotto la guida
dell'eroico William Wallace contro i malvagi dominatori inglesi. Anche lì a un certo punto
lo Ius Primen Octis entra in gioco per far andare avanti la trama. È una scena curiosissima.
Il re d'Inghilterra, malvagio ovviamente, sta discutendo con i suoi baroni e a un certo
punto dice il problema della Scozia è che è piena di scozzesi. Ma io ho trovato il modo
di farla finita con gli scozzesi. È venuto il momento di rimettere in uso una vecchia tradizione.
Concediamo lo Ius Primen Octis. D'ora in poi i nostri nobili avranno diritto ad andare
a letto con le ragazze scozzesi prima che si sposino. E in questo modo il sottinteso è
che si imbastardirà la razza di questi ribelli. Notate, mentre nel romanzo di Falcones, con
un bel coraggio, l'autore ha provato a immaginare un mondo in cui lo Ius Primen Octis esiste come
una cosa che non si può evitare di accettare. È un obbligo, è una legge e nessuno si ribella.
Nel film Braveheart, capirete poi perché è importante sottolineare questo aspetto, è un po' diversa
la prospettiva. Il re dice rimettiamo in uso una vecchia consuetudine. È, ben inteso, la conseguenza
quando gli inglesi cominciano a pretendere lo Ius Primen Octis è che gli scozzesi insorgono
definitivamente. E questo è un nesso che ritroviamo spessissimo quando si racconta
dello Ius Primen Octis. Ci sono un sacco di cittadine o paesini italiani che nella loro
tradizione, nella loro leggenda, hanno un lontano passato in cui un malvagio feudatario
opprimeva gli abitanti pretendendo lo Ius Primen Octis. Fino a quando, naturalmente, una
ragazza più coraggiosa degli altri o un marito più coraggioso degli altri, si ribellano
e mettono fine alla tirannia. È un lungo elenco, dando vedere su internet si potrebbe
aggiungerne ancora altri. Quanti sono i luoghi che hanno nella loro memoria, memoria, nella
loro tradizione, questa storia? Fiuggi, Sant'Agata di Puglia, Rocca Scalegna in Abruzzo,
parecchi paesi in Liguria, Montalto Ligure, Onzo, parecchi paesi in Piemonte, Nizza Monferrato,
Rocca Grimalda, perfino Ivrea, dove il carnevale di Ivrea, sapete il carnevale in cui si gettano
le arance, all'origine, secondo quel che si racconta oggi, ha un episodio in cui un malvagio
tiranno pretendeva lo Ius Primen Octis, fino a quando una ragazza più sveglia degli altri
si ribella, la bella mugnaia Violetta. Apro una piccola parentesi, per immaginare quanto
è antica questa storia, basta pensare che il nome Violetta nel Medioevo, non sapevano
neanche cosa fosse, il nome Violetta diventa di moda nell'Ottocento con la Traviata. Prima
non c'è nessuno che si chiami Violetta. Chiusa parentesi, perché non voglio influenzare
il vostro giudizio. Dunque, mi pare che abbiamo assodato, primo punto, che nella cultura di
oggi, sia nel folklore locale, sia nella cultura degli autori di romanzi storici e degli sceneggiatori,
e quindi anche di tutti noi che quei film li guardiamo e quei romanzi li leggiamo, lo Ius
Primen Octis è una presenza abbastanza regolare quando si parla di Medioevo. Come sapete la scommessa
di queste nostre serate è di dire, beh, andiamo a controllare, andiamo a vedere che testimonianze
ci sono nel Medioevo dell'esistenza dello Ius Primen Octis, andiamo a cercarle. Adesso
vi proporrò rapidamente due possibili percorsi, andiamo a vedere nelle testimonianze, nelle fonti
che ci sono arrivate dal Medioevo, dove si parla dello Ius Primen Octis, dove possiamo
andare a cercare. Una prima idea è di andare a cercare nella letteratura, nelle novelle,
in quella letteratura realistica che descrive situazioni reali. Nel Medioevo hanno grandissimo
successo, piacciono moltissimo, e se ne scrivono un sacco, le novelle tipo quelle del Boccaccio.
Quelle del Boccaccio noi italiani le conosciamo bene, ma esistono generi letterari simili anche
negli altri paesi. C'è un'immensa produzione di questi testi, i quali hanno queste caratteristiche.
Sono di solito molto realistici, rappresentano situazioni reali dell'epoca, personaggi reali,
e sono molto espliciti. Di sesso si parla molto, e se ne parla senza farsi nessun problema.
Si parla di sesso per raccontare di beffe riuscite, per far vedere come i poveri riescono
a resistere ai soprusi dei ricchi. Si parla di sesso per vedere come l'astuzia, anche
in quelle situazioni lì, conti e serva molto. Ci sono le novelle del Boccaccio, ma c'è
un altro genere. Mi fermo un secondo su questo. In Francia, già prima del Boccaccio, già nel
200, c'è un genere letterario, si chiamano i fablio. Sono dei poemetti brevi, inversi,
perché il gusto di allora era quello. Molto divertenti di solito, che un po' come le
novelle nostre raccontano burle, scherzi, beffe, episodi strani. E anche lì di sesso
si parla continuamente, ripeto, in modo realistico. C'è il prete del villaggio che insidia la moglie
del ciabattino. E si sa che al villaggio il prete è quello che ha studiato, è quello che
parla meglio, è quello che ha più soldi. E quindi, insomma, ha successo con le parrocchiane.
C'è lo studente di passaggio, ospitato per una notte dal mugnaio, e che quella notte
mette gli occhi sulla figlia del mugnaio. E così via. Anche qui con una estrema libertà,
anche di linguaggio, nel descrivere queste situazioni. Uno direbbe, se c'è un posto dove
qualche autore doveva parlarci dello ius primen octis, sarà bene in questa novellistica
medievale. Che argomento, che espediente narrativo lo ius primen octis? Non si trova
mai. Non c'è una singola novella medievale, una singola barzelletta o storia di sesso medievale,
e ce ne sono innumerevoli, che parli mai dello ius primen octis. Non parlano del fatto che
magari il signore del villaggio mette gli occhi sulle ragazze. È certo che ne parlano,
perché il signore del villaggio mette come gli occhi sulle ragazze. Come ne parlano?
Vi faccio un esempio. Una novella francese del Quattrocento. Nel Quattrocento esce in Francia
una raccolta di novelle che è un po' copiata sul Decameron come struttura. Sono cento.
Si chiamano Le Cento Novelle Nuove, Le Cent Nouvelles Nouvelles. La novella 24 racconta di un conte
che a un certo punto viene a sapere che in uno dei suoi villaggi c'è una bella ragazza. Il conte è
un bravo uomo, però insomma non butta via le occasioni. Quindi va a dare un'occhiata. La ragazza
è veramente carina ed è una sua suddita. A questo punto cosa fa il conte? Le manda un
mezzano, le manda un suo servo per dirle guarda che tu al conte piaci, se sei furba, se ci stai,
la tua fortuna è fatta, la tua, della tua famiglia. La ragazza risponde io sono una suddita del
conte. Sono pronta a obbedire a qualunque suo ordine, salvo il mio onore. Ma se mi vogliono
chiedere qualcosa contro il mio onore, a cui tengo più che alla mia stessa vita, io il conte neanche lo
conosco. Il servo va dal conte e gli riferisce questa risposta. Il conte ci rimane male e siccome ormai
si è messo nell'idea va in giro intorno al villaggio della ragazza. Finalmente la trova da sola.
La ragazza è da sola che sta tagliando l'erba vicino al bosco. Arriva il conte e comincia a corteggiarla
un po' bruscamente e la ragazza non vorrebbe starci e il conte diventa molto intraprendente e le dice
se ti stai ferma perché comunque non mi scappi. A questo punto la ragazza, e tutto il succo della novella
naturalmente sta nella trovata della ragazza per sfuggire a questa situazione imbarazzante,
a questo punto la ragazza gli dice vabbè, vista la situazione d'accordo, ci sto, però senti,
ti chiedo solo una cosa, togliti i pantaloni perché mi fanno male. Il conte era pronto a
sbottonarsi i pantaloni e basta. Hai pantaloni da cavallo, aderentissimi, di pelle, difficilissimi
da sfilare. Lui non se li toglieva mica. Però dice vabbè dai se vuoi che me li tolga
dai togli meli perché io da solo non ci riesco. Si sdraia, la ragazza comincia a tirare questi
pantaloni aderentissimi. Quando è arrivata a metà salta su e dice io vado. Il conte salta
in piedi, precipita per terra perché non può muoversi con i pantaloni infilati in quel
modo. La ragazza si mette in salvo, il conte ci pensa un po', si mette a ridere, trova
che la ragazza ha avuto spirito e dato che è un bravuomo in realtà ci mette una croce
sopra e anzi alla prima occasione organizza un grande matrimonio con un altro nobile per
questa ragazza, le dà una grossa dote per ricompensarla del suo spirito. Con tutta la
buona volontà, se c'era una novella in cui magari un piccolo accenno al fatto che lui bastava
dicesse c'ho il diritto o lo just for him no, niente. Ci sono delle novelle medievali
in cui ogni tanto però viene fuori questa idea della prestazione sessuale come una specie
di tassa, come una specie di obbligo. Qualche novella c'è, ma in un orizzonte completamente
diverso da quello dello just for him noctis come lo immaginiamo noi. Ve ne racconto una per
darvi un esempio. Siamo sempre in questa raccolta francese del Quattrocento. È una
novella che racconta cosa è successo quando i francescani si sono stabiliti per la prima
volta in Catalogna, nella città di Gerona. Hanno costruito il loro convento e hanno cominciato
a fare quello che i frati fanno sempre, cioè a parlare con la gente, a confessare i penitenti,
a dare buoni consigli. E come sempre succede, molta gente va dai francescani a confessarsi.
Anche molte donne, anche molte donne carine. E com'è, com'è non è dopo un po' i francescani
cominciano a... così. Ci sono tutte queste belle penitenti e ai francescani viene voglia.
Sto sempre raccontando questa novella quattrocentesca. Come vedete nel Medioevo non si fanno problemi
a raccontare le storie, non ha paura di offendere nessuno. A un certo punto uno dei francescani
ha un'idea geniale. Quando gli viene la bella penitente a confessarsi, il francescano le
dice, cara la mia donna, qui però devi sapere che noi francescani abbiamo anche dei diritti,
ce li ha dati il Papa. Anche tu devi pagare la tua parte. Io, prontissima, cosa devo fare?
E dice, sai che si paga la decima, no? E certo, tu paghi la decima al Signore, paghi la decima
al parroco e anche noi francescani abbiamo diritto a una decima. Alla decima di tutte
le notti d'amore tra te e tuo marito. Quindi sappi, mia cara, che d'ora in poi devi tenere
il conto e venire a pagare la decima. Parrocchiana, convintissima, paga la decima. E gli altri francescani
dopo un po' scoprono il trucco e tutte le parrocchiane vengono a sapere che bisogna pagare la decima
delle notti d'amore e sono tutte molto convinte e con grande zelo per salvarsi l'anima vengono
al convento a pagare la decima. Poi vabbè, la novella finisce male, nel senso che i mariti
se ne accorgono, se la prendono un po', bruciano il convento con tutti i frati dentro e così
finisce. È una barzelletta, come capite, è una storia. Ci dimostra che questa gente
al sesso ci pensava e che lo sapeva che c'era un nesso fra il sesso e il potere, che il sesso
è una partita complicata, è una situazione sociale complessa, che succedono tante cose
in ambito sessuale. Però con tutta la buona volontà lo ius primen octis, come lo conosciamo
noi, meno di zero. Proviamo a fare un'altra verifica. Lo ius primen octis è conosciuto
come uno degli obblighi del contadino verso il suo signore. Siamo informati noi su quali
fossero in generale gli obblighi dei contadini verso i signori. Sappiamo in particolare quali
erano gli obblighi che pesavano di più, che davano fastidio, contro cui ci si ribellava.
Lo sappiamo e come. Noi abbiamo una documentazione immensa sulle lamentele dei contadini medievali
contro tutti gli obblighi che erano costretti a subire nella signoria. Perché succedeva
di tutto? Succedeva, per esempio, a un certo punto comincia a succedere abbastanza spesso
che i contadini, che intanto hanno fatto i soldi, e sono stufi di avere certi obblighi,
sono stufi di dover andare, che ne so, ogni notte ci deve essere un uomo di guardia sulla
torre del castello. Quindi tutte le famiglie a turno devono mandare un uomo. È una bella seccatura.
Oppure, per parlare di cose ancora più impegnative perché toccano i soldi, le terre del villaggio
sono tutte del Signore. I contadini hanno il diritto di gestirle in perpetuo, però pagano
l'affitto. I contadini se le possono anche vendere fra loro, ma sono sempre del Signore
e devono pagare al Signore una certa tassa quando comprano o vendono le sue terre. E in molte
signorie il Signore dice che quando il mio uomo muore, se ha dei figli, loro si ereditano
le terre, che sono mie. Ma se non ha figli maschi, le terre me le riprendo io. Non permetto
al mio contadino di decidere lui di far testamento e lasciare in eredità la terra magari a una
donna, che poi magari sposa uno di un altro villaggio e non si sa cosa succede. Nella
mia signoria testamento non si fa. I contadini dopo un po' sono seccati di tutto questo.
E molto spesso, anzi quasi dappertutto, non c'è quasi villaggio in Europa dove prima o
poi nel Medioevo non succeda che i contadini si siedono a un tavolo insieme col Signore
e mettono i soldi sul tavolo e dicono noi vorremmo abolire quest'obbligo, quest'altro,
quest'altro e quest'altro. In cambio paghiamo. E si fa una bella pergabena, si scrive tutto.
Se poi il Signore non è d'accordo, capita che i contadini vanno dal Re e gli dicono
noi non stiamo bene col nostro Signore. Come mai? Perché pretende questo, quest'altro
e quest'altro. E questo lo pagavano già i nostri nonni, pazienza, ma quest'altra cosa
che pretende è una novità, è un abuso. Noi non vogliamo farla questa cosa. E il Re si
mette in mezzo e giudica e si va per avvocati e i contadini pagano un avvocato e arrivano
in memoriali. Noi abbiamo negli archivi scartafacci enormi, con gli elenchi di tutti
gli obblighi di questi contadini che non ne possono più e sono disposti a tutto pur
di eliminarli, questi obblighi. E se anche il processo non va bene, capita che i contadini
si ribellano. Si ribellano e magari fanno anche fuori il Signore, oppure il Signore più
facilmente scappa e poi dopo un po' ci si rimette d'accordo, magari c'è scappato il
morto, ma alla fine si fa la pace e di nuovo si scrive tutto. L'elenco degli obblighi
che pesavano sui contadini medievali, ne ho appena accennato qualcuno a titolo di esempio,
erano tantissimi questi obblighi e di tutti ci si lamentava e per tutti si pagava pur di
riscattarli. Voi avete già capito, dello ius primen octis non si parla mai. Non c'è
un elenco di lamentele contadine che accenni a questo obbligo. Questa gente che è disposta
a pagare un sacco di quattrini per non avere più la scocciatura di dover fare un turno
di lavoro alla settimana nei fossati del castello non accenna minimamente allo ius primen
octis. Ora a quel punto facciamo una considerazione di metodo. L'argomento che parte dal silenzio
bisogna trattarlo con attenzione. Non basta dire di questa cosa non si parla mai, quindi
non c'era. Questa è una regola generale del mestiere, però è anche vero che ci sono
dei casi in cui se di una cosa non si parla mai e invece avrebbero dovuto parlarne come
se ci fosse stata. Ci sono dei casi in cui francamente l'argomento da silenzio ti mette
un po' in crisi. Non c'è fino al quattrocento e quindi per quasi tutto il medioevo non esiste
nessuna testimonianza che parli di qualcosa che assomiglia allo ius primen octis. Anche
se certe volte si trova qualcosa che ci aiuta a capire come è poi nata questa, che a questo
punto mi sento di definire questa leggenda. A volte troviamo qualche indizio che ci fa
capire com'è che la gente ha cominciato a ricamare su questa fantasia. Vi cito il caso
più antico che si è trovato. È un documento del 1247. Siamo in Francia. È un elenco dei
soliti obblighi dei contadini di un villaggio. Siccome quel villaggio appartiene per metà
a un signore laico e per metà ai monaci di un monastero, il signore e i monaci litigano
spesso, quel pezzo tocca a me, quell'altro tocca a te, e allora a un certo punto fanno
una bella lista scritta di tutti gli obblighi. Fra gli obblighi dei contadini di questo villaggio
di Verson nella Francia del 200 c'è il seguente obbligo. Quando un contadino sposa sua figlia,
se sposa un ragazzo di un altro villaggio, deve pagare una tassa. Chiarimento. Questo non è niente
di strano e niente di nuovo. È una clausola che è molto frequente nella vita dei contadini
medievali e, se non vi annoia troppo, vi spiego anche come mai esiste questa clausola. Seguitemi.
Il contadino lavora nel villaggio e lavora terra del signore e gli paga l'affitto. Quando si sposa
sua figlia, magari le dà in dote una parte di quella terra. Tanto il genero continuerà a lavorare
quella terra e a pagare l'affitto al signore. Non c'è nessun problema. Ma se il genero è uno
di un altro villaggio, chi garantisce al signore che poi si riesce a obbligarlo a pagare l'affitto,
che lui lavorerà davvero, che verrà a risiedere lì? Non lo garantisce nessuno. È un altro villaggio,
c'è un altro signore. Quindi il signore di Verson, come i signori di innumerevoli altri
villaggi medievali, non è contento se le figlie dei suoi contadini sposano un ragazzo
di un altro villaggio. E quindi dice se proprio lo volete fare mi dovete pagare. Per dare il
mio consenso voglio essere pagato. Questa tassa dunque è diffusissima. Ma noi stiamo
raccontando il caso specifico del villaggio di Verson 1247. C'è questo elenco in latino
che elenca tutti questi obblighi. Un monaco di quella abbazia si è divertito a un certo
punto, avendo poco da fare, a scrivere una poesiola in francese, in rima, che elenca questi
stessi obblighi. Traduce in latino e in versi questo elenco di obblighi. E a un certo punto
fa un'aggiunta. Quando è arrivato alla tassa che i contadini devono pagare, quando si sposa
la loro figlia con un ragazzo di un altro paese, il monaco dice oggi si pagano tre
soldi. Ma ai contadini va bene perché una volta era molto peggio. C'è stata un'epoca
in cui si pagava così tanto che i contadini non ce la facevano certe volte a pagare. E
c'erano dei padri di famiglia che piuttosto di dover dare al signore un capo di bestiame
o una vigna o una rendita, gli portavano la figlia e gli dicevano senti fai quello che
vuoi, basta che mi abbuoni la tassa. Questa è la primissima menzione in un testo medievale,
fra i milioni di testi e documenti medievali, di una cosa che assomiglia vagamente allo Ius
primen octis. Perché dico vagamente, notate, perché non se ne parla come di un diritto
e se ne parla come di una cosa che fa il padre pur di non dover pagare la pesante tassa.
Ma soprattutto la cosa importante è che già in questa primissima menzione, come vedremo
in seguito succederà regolarmente, si parla dello Ius primen octis o di una cosa che gli
assomiglia, scusatemi, di una cosa che gli assomiglia dicendo nei brutti vecchi tempi.
E questa è la chiave per capire come alla fine del Medioevo hanno cominciato a fantasticare
su quello che succedeva nei brutti vecchi tempi.
Alla fine del Medioevo ci sono molte località, villaggi o anche città, che sono state create
secoli prima da gruppi di contadini che si sono messi d'accordo, hanno abbandonato il
villaggio, hanno detto arrivederci al Signore, si sono fondati la loro città e sono andati
a vivere liberi in questa città.
È un fenomeno frequentissimo nel Medioevo.
In certe regioni è più frequente che in altre.
Per ragioni varie e casuali è molto frequente in Piemonte, per esempio, dove parecchie città
da Cuneo ad Alessandria a Cherasco sono nate con questo meccanismo.
Proprio a Cuneo, alla fine del Quattrocento, succede questo.
Sono passati 300 anni dalla fondazione della città.
Alla fine del Quattrocento un erudito di Cuneo, l'avvocato Rebaccini, decide di scrivere
la storia di Cuneo e racconta come è nata Cuneo, che i nostri antenati tanto tempo fa hanno
deciso di abbandonare i loro signori e di lasciare i loro villaggi e di andare a vivere
in una nuova città.
E dice l'avvocato Rebaccini, se ne sono andati perché era pesante stare sotto il dominio
dei signori.
E comincia ad elencare tutta una serie di angherie che i signori facevano ai loro contadini.
E non gli permettevano di fare testamento e li costringevano a pagare ogni volta che qualcuno
doveva vendere una terra, prendevano la decima, prendevano la taglia, su ogni contratto prendevano
una quota, li costringevano a fare prestazioni di lavoro gratis, dice l'avvocato Rebaccini,
li costringevano a lavorare senza discressione.
Perché se l'avessero fatto con discressione, ma invece così no.
E notate che tutte queste lamentele corrispondono esattamente a quello che i documenti di 300 anni
prima ci dicono, davvero nelle signorie c'erano questi obblighi e questo peso.
L'avvocato Rebaccini racconta e racconta come erano brutti quei vecchi tempi, come erano
tiranni quei feudatari.
E poi alla fine, quando ha proprio finito tutto, finalmente, sottomettendo la ragione
alla libidine e sensualità, defloravano le figlie dei sudditi e parimente le spose.
Persuadendo a sudditi questa essere loro antica ragione e privilegio loro concesso.
Come il Rebaccini a Cuneo, così nel 500 e nel 600, in parecchie città italiane e francesi,
c'è un bravo cittadino che si mette a raccontare la storia della città
e che comincia da quando 300 anni prima, 400 anni prima, i trisnonni si sono ribellati
ai cattivi signori e a molti di questi, ormai entra in circolo questa cosa, erano proprio
cattivi quei signori e pretendevano perfino questa cosa.
Se uno non pagava, si prendevano la verginità delle ragazze.
In altre parole, arrivati al 4-500, noi ci troviamo di fronte, quindi tra la fine del Medioevo
e il Rinascimento, noi di colpo ci troviamo di fronte a un'Europa dove il racconto
dello Ius Primen Octis è entrato in circolo e comincia a ritornare fuori e torna fuori
sempre, sempre, con questa caratteristica, che si parla di un passato lontanissimo.
Ai brutti vecchi tempi succedevano queste cose.
No, non è vero, non è sempre che si parla dei brutti vecchi tempi da noi.
C'è anche un altro modo in cui nell'Europa del 4-500 circola la storia dello Ius Primen Octis.
Non da noi nei brutti vecchi tempi, ma adesso presso i selvaggi.
L'Europa del 4-500, facciamo un po' di contesto in fretta, è l'Europa delle grandi scoperte
geografiche. Nel corso del 4-100 i portoghesi si sono inoltrati nell'Atlantico, hanno attraversato,
sono scesi sotto il capo di Buona Speranza, ovunque hanno scoperto nuove terre.
E poi alla fine del 4-100 naturalmente parte Colombo e arriva in America e poi nel primo
500 vanno i conquistadores. È tutto un insieme di mondi nuovi che vengono scoperti.
Ogni volta i navigatori che arrivano in un posto nuovo pubblicano delle relazioni, dove
raccontano che posto è questo. Queste relazioni dei navigatori e dei conquistatori portoghesi
e spagnoli si assomigliano tutte. Gli abitanti di queste isole sono dei selvaggi. Voi non vi
immaginate che selvaggi sono. Vanno nudi, non hanno nessuna morale, fanno le cose peggiori.
Figuratevi che da loro, quando uno si sposa, il capo del villaggio ha il diritto di andare
a letto con la ragazza. E certe volte non sono il capo del villaggio. Se si sposa un commerciante,
tutti i commercianti vanno. Si sposa un nobile, tutti i nobili. Se invece è un plebeo, va il
padrone, naturalmente. Quando i portoghesi scoprono le Canarie a metà Quattrocento, raccontano
questo. Quando Alvise Cadamosto va a Tenerife, dice che a Tenerife succede questo. Quando Cortes
va in Messico, racconta, anzi prima ancora a Cuba, racconta che a Cuba succedeva questo.
È chiaro perché raccontano questo? Perché noi, questi popoli selvaggi, li stiamo riducendo
in schiavitù, se non sterminando. Perché gli stiamo portando, se Dio vuole, la ragione
e la vera fede. E di conseguenza bisogna dimostrare che ne hanno un gran bisogno che arriviamo noi
a portargli la civiltà. Questi selvaggi sono veramente al di sotto dell'umano. Fanno cose
inconcepibili. Va da sé che nessuno spagnolo o portoghese sia mai sognato che nel suo mondo
succedano quelle cose lì, perché altrimenti non gli verrebbe da presentarle come un esempio
di stranezza. E invece quando si parla dei selvaggi tutto va bene.
Diciamo anche una cosa, perché poi le cose sono sempre più complesse e il mondo non è
fatto tutto in modo in un altro. Escono questi libri, ne escono tanti, la gente ci crede,
c'è anche qualcuno che protesta. La relazione di Cortes, in cui dice che a Cuba succedevano
queste brutte cose, viene pubblicata da Francisco López de Gomara nella storia generale delle
Indie occidentali e delle nuove terre scoperte e c'è qualcuno che protesta. Perché in quell'Europa
così strana, dopo tutto, c'è anche qualcuno che dice ma non è vero niente, noi stiamo
facendo torto a questi Indios, bisogna difenderli, è una vergogna quello che gli stiamo facendo.
La Scasas, il Gesuita, il quale precisamente parlando di questo libro dice che questo libro
denigra quei popoli, non è vero niente e arriva a farlo proibire dal re, perché calunnia
gli Indios. Intanto però l'ha tradotto in francese, lo legge Montaigne, lo leggono tutti
e insomma queste storie continuano a circolare. Allora, rifacciamo il punto. Nell'Europa del
4-500 la storia dello Ius Primae Noctis circola ampiamente. Ci sono due possibilità.
Succedeva da noi nei brutti vecchi tempi oppure succede adesso fra i selvaggi. Fra i selvaggi,
fra i barbari, perché poi ognuno ha il barbaro che vuole avere. Nell'Inghilterra tra
5 e 600, l'Inghilterra della gran regina Elisabetta e di Shakespeare, c'è un paese che i bravi
inglesi considerano non barbaro e selvaggio, anzi sarebbe un paese molto civile, però si
è imbarbarito orrendamente. È un paese che è in un abisso di nefandezza ed è l'Italia
naturalmente. È l'Italia dove da una parte comanda il Papa e per i bravi protestanti inglesi
il papismo è ciò che c'è di peggio al mondo e contemporaneamente in Italia c'è
Machiavelli, il cinico, l'immorale. Ecco l'Italia per gli inglesi del primo 600 è il
paese più immorale del mondo. Nel 1619 va in scena a Londra una commedia scritta da due
autori di successo, Beaumont e Fletcher, si intitola The Custom of the Country, l'usanza
del paese e racconta di un paese, una città così barbara che in quella città il governatore
esige lo ius primen octis su tutte le donne che in quella città si sposano, finché naturalmente
è una coppia più energica delle altre, si ribelle eccetera eccetera eccetera. Dov'è
quella città? Ma in Italia naturalmente. In buona sostanza lo ius primen octis è diventato
per gli intellettuali, i letterati ma anche per il pubblico del 4500 un argomento formidabile
per descrivere tutti quei mondi che non ci piacciono, che consideriamo barbari, che sia
il lontano passato medievale o che sia il presente dei selvaggi o degli italiani a seconda
dei casi appunto. Non basta. A questo punto succede un'altra cosa che serve a consolidare
la leggenda che lo ius primen octis ai brutti vecchi tempi è esistito davvero. Il 500 è
epoca di giuristi. Epoca di giuristi che cominciano a analizzare in particolare gli obblighi
dei contadini, le consuetudini delle signorie, le consuetudini feudali come si comincia a dire
a quell'epoca. Questi giuristi in Francia per esempio sono al servizio del re e il re sarebbe
ben contento di ridimensionare un po' il potere dei signori. Nella cultura di questi giuristi il
potere dei signori comincia a sembrare un'anticaglia, una cosa che andrebbe eliminata. Ricordiamoci
che nel 1789, dopo due secoli e mezzo di ragionamenti di questo tipo, finalmente con la
rivoluzione francese la prima cosa che fanno è l'abolizione del regime feudale. Tutto
questo comincia nel 500. I giuristi del 500 analizzano, scoprono che in molte signorie
si paga una tassa sul matrimonio. Ora i giuristi del 500, intanto sono gente che ha una cultura
come dire anche, amano divertirsi, amano anche loro le novelle un po' sconce, è il secolo
dell'aretino, è il secolo di Rablè, nelle università si scherza e ci si diverte molto
e tutti questi giuristi sono stati studenti prima di diventare giuristi. E insomma sanno
anche che molto spesso quando un contadino paga una tassa è perché prima c'era un servizio
in natura e poi il contadino l'ha riscattato. Abbiamo visto questo meccanismo. Quando il giurista,
voi immaginate il giurista, la sua scrivania, carica di codici, è dotissimo ma è anche pronto
a credere qualunque cosa. Deve spiegare, perché i giuristi dell'epoca devono spiegare
come mai si paga questa tassa. C'è una tassa sui matrimoni, il contadino quando fa sposare
sua figlia deve pagare. Non è che prima c'era un servizio in natura che adesso è stato
riscattato. E certo, deve essere così per forza. Dovunque trovano una tassa sui matrimoni
i giuristi immaginano che prima ci fosse lo ius primen octis. E vengono fuori interi
trattati dove questa informazione viene somministrata come se fosse ormai un dato di fatto.
Ormai si sa che in passato succedeva questo. E anche gli storici ormai leggendo i giuristi
e se non lo sanno loro. Poi gli storici quando manca un pezzo inventano. C'è un libro che
ha un'enorme influenza. Esce nel 1526. È una storia della Scozia di un autore che si
chiama Boetius, Hector Boetius. Per darvi un'idea di quanto è attendibile la storia della
Scozia di Boetius, che pure è un intellettuale del Rinascimento, un dotto umanista, per darvi
un'idea di quanto è attendibile, vi dirò che secondo lui la Scozia è stata fondata
da una principessa che si chiamava Scozia e che era la figlia del faraone, quello di
Mosè, quello della Bibbia. In quest'opera di cui potete apprezzare la credibilità, Boetius
dice che da noi in Scozia i contadini pagano una tassa sul matrimonio. Questa tassa è stata
introdotta dal buon re Malcolm nell'undicesimo secolo per consiglio di sua moglie, la santa
regina Margherita, per sostituire una tassa precedente, non una tassa, un obbligo precedente,
un obbligo nefando, immondo, che non oso neanche dirvi cosa fosse, che fu introdotto tanti secoli
prima ai tempi dei barbari, dei celti, dal re Eveno di Scozia. L'obbligo per cui appunto
le ragazze con il signore eccetera eccetera eccetera, con tutta la buona volontà cascano
proprio le ginocchia, perché? Per carità il re Malcolm è esistito e anche sua moglie
Margherita, ovviamente non hanno mai fatto niente del genere, il re Eveno fa il paio con
la principessa Scozia, figlia del faraone, è inventato di sana pianta, perché questi
quando non sanno riempire i vuoti inventano. E i libri girano, i libri li leggono tutti.
Già, dimenticavo, vi dico questa. Io ho raccontato due o tre di queste cose, ma non il fatto di
Boetius della Scozia. Ho raccontato qualcosa sullo Ius Primen Octis in un articolo che è
uscito sulla stampa tre o quattro giorni fa, dove dicevo guardate che lo Ius Primen Octis
è una leggenda, così e così. Stamattina apro la posta, mi ha scritto un signore gentilissimo
dicendomi, caro professore ho letto il suo articolo, lo Ius Primen Octis, certo sarà una
leggenda, però a me risulta che in qualche caso esisteva davvero nel dizionario storico
del Ducange si dice che in Scozia il re Eveno aveva introdotto lo Ius, io l'ho letto stamattina
nell'oposta questo. Quindi come vedete le cose circolano, i giuristi credono a tutto,
bisogna dire che ogni tanto la situazione le aiuta anche. Le imposte che i contadini pagavano
nel Medioevo avevano tanti nomi, ce ne erano molte per esempio che avevano un nome che parte
dall'idea della colletta, colletta lo sappiamo tutti cosa vuol dire raccogliere soldi e quindi
in molti casi quando il signore faceva il giro diceva è ora di pagare, quella cosa
si chiamava la colletta. Colletta in toscano ma nelle varie lingue d'Europa prendeva vari
nomi, in francese spesso si chiamava queillage per esempio, si chiamava queillage nella lingua
comune una tassa che si pagava in varie occasioni, a volte anche la tassa sul matrimonio si chiamava
queillage. Ma naturalmente la gente la chiamava queillage ma nei documenti latini il notaio
si sforzava di tradurre in latino questa parola della lingua parlata. E certi notai, magari
proprio perché si divertivano anche loro da matti a prendere per i fondelli i contadini
e i loro signori questi rozzi ignoranti, certi notai quando dovevano trascrivere in latino
la parola queillage scrivevano culagium. Voi immaginate i giuristi del Cinquecento quando
scoprono che il contadino quando si sposa sua figlia deve pagare al signore una tassa
che si chiama culagium. È la fine del mondo.
Ma non basta. Altro esempio. Nel Medioevo è universalmente diffuso un nome per indicare
le imposte che è una parola che oggi non è più usata, molti di voi non l'avranno mai
sentita, fodro. La parola fodro gli specialisti di storia medievale la conoscono benissimo e
nella lingua parlata non esiste più oggi invece. È una parola dall'origine molto chiara in realtà,
è la stessa parola dell'inglese fodder che vuol dire foraggio, cibo per gli animali. Si paga
un'imposta per nutrire i cavalli del re o del signore. Fodro. Ma gli eruditi del Cinque,
del Sei, del Settecento dopo un po' non conoscono più l'origine di questa parola. Si paga il fodro.
Cosa sarà mai? A Nizza Monferrato, allora chiamata Nizza della Paglia in Piemonte, si paga
il fodro. A Nizza Monferrato la leggenda locale dice che i contadini hanno fondato il paese
ribellandosi contro un cattivo signore. Nel Settecento arriva un erudito, l'abate Giulio
Cesare Cordara, che mette insieme le due cose. A Nizza Monferrato c'era il cattivo signore e si
pagava un'imposta che si chiamava il fodro. Fodro. Cosa sarà mai questo fodro? Fodero. Ecco da dove
viene fodero. Il fodero. Ma cos'è questo fodero? Sarà un'immagine, una metafora? Il fodero, la guaina,
la vagina. Ecco cos'è il fodero. Ecco cos'era che dovevano pagare questi poveri contadini. E l'abate
a ricordare alla fine del Settecento scrive un poema, il fodero, ossia il ius sulle spose
degli antichi signori di Nizza Monferrato. Un passettino in là. Una volta che tutti
si sono convinti che nel passato esistevano questi diritti, si va a cercare altre prove.
e andando a cercare altre prove le trovi. Esempio. Esempio di un documento che è stato
citato da innumerevoli studiosi come la prova che non solo nel Medioevo esisteva lo ius
premen octis, ma perfino la Chiesa lo pretendeva dai suoi contadini. È un processo che si celebra
davanti al Parlamento di Parigi e che riguarda la diocesi di Amiens. Siamo alla fine del
Trecento. Qual è la premessa? Nel Medioevo la Chiesa, come oggi e forse ancora più di
oggi, anzi spesso più di oggi, si sforzava di ricordare ai cristiani che il sesso nel
matrimonio ci sta anche bene, ma deve essere tenuto sotto controllo, perché è finalizzato
esclusivamente alla procreazione e di conseguenza nel sesso non bisogna lasciarsi andare troppo,
neanche nel matrimonio, anzi è cosa buona e giusta imparare a tenere sotto controllo
la libidine. Capita in qualche diocesi medievale che i vescovi comincino a spiegare ai loro fedeli
che sarebbe una bella cosa se quando si sposano per tre giorni rimanessero casti, in modo da
dimostrare che sanno dominare la loro libidine e che non si sposano per quello. In certe diocesi
questo diventa in un modo o nell'altro un obbligo che la Chiesa impone. Quando ti sposi
per tre giorni non puoi consumare il matrimonio. Dopodiché il basso Medioevo, l'alto Medioevo
prima del 1000 è un'epoca stagnante, dopo no, dopo fanno i soldi tutti, girano soldi
a non finire e diventano anche molto sbrigativi e molto cinici, si paga per tutto. Nel basso
Medioevo molta gente comincia a dire, sì vabbè mi sposo, dovrei fare i tre giorni
di castità, ma se invece facessi un'offerta alla Chiesa? E la Chiesa dice, benissimo,
fai l'offerta. Dopo un po' non c'è più nessuno che osserva i tre giorni di castità,
ma ci sono diocesi dove è normale che chi si sposa deve pagare una certa tassa alla Chiesa.
Come la chiamano? In vari modi, ma perlopiù la tassa della prima notte di nozze. Perché
io pago proprio per quello. A fine 300, e storia vecchia anche questa, nella diocesi
di Amiens la gente non la paga più, il vescovo si secca e fa un processo per costringere la
gente a continuare a pagare questa tassa. La gente protesta, si va al Parlamento di Parigi,
viene fuori un processo che dura, i tempi non erano tanto diversi dai nostri, 16 anni e
alla fine non mi ricordo neanche più cosa decide il Parlamento di Parigi, ma insomma
comunque questo processo, voi lo immaginate, sono faldoni così, in latino, di ragionamenti
giuridici in latino. Quando gli storici del Settecento e dell'Ottocento scoprono questo
processo, e non è che stanno a leggere tutto proprio, non si capisce niente, però una cosa
si capisce, si parla di una tassa sulla prima notte di matrimonio ed era la Chiesa che
pretendeva dai contadini la tassa sulla prima notte di matrimonio, è la prova che lo Ius
Primenoctis esisteva. Ultima cosa, la più curiosa se vogliamo, tra 4 e 500 un po' tutti
si convincono che nei brutti vecchi tempi lo Ius Primenoctis esisteva. Anche i signori
sentono dire questa cosa, perché la signoria esiste ancora, fino all'abolizione del regime
feudale con la rivoluzione francese la signoria esiste, i signori sono meno potenti di prima,
il re gli ha tolto parecchi poteri, parecchie entrate, però comunque il contadino ha ancora
sempre a che fare col signore e paga tante tasse. I signori vengono a sapere che in passato
esisteva questo Ius Primenoctis, sta a vedere che esisteva anche della mia signoria, i miei
avi sicuramente avevano diritto. Allora le reazioni possibili sono due, c'è un erudito
dell'inizio del 600 che ci racconta questa storia, dice io ho parlato col cardinale
Gerolamo della Rovere, importante cardinale, nobile famiglia, fine 500, il cardinale Gerolamo
della Rovere mi ha detto che questo ignobile diritto esisteva anche nella sua famiglia e
che lui stesso ha bruciato la pergamena che dava ai della Rovere il diritto dello Ius Primenoctis.
Chissà cosa c'era in quella pergamena, un imposto sul matrimonio, il culagium, va a sapere
cosa c'era, il cardinale l'ha presa per buona, siccome era un cardinale l'ha bruciato, ai
nostri tempi civili queste cose non si fanno più. Ma ci sono anche dei signori che non
sono dei cardinali e che si fanno meno scrupoli, ci sono dei signori che magari litigano spesso
con i loro contadini, anzi i signori litigano continuamente con i contadini perché è un
bel dire i diritti sono questi, gli obblighi sono questi, la gente non vuole pagare le tasse,
quindi si litiga continuamente, si va in processi e ogni tanto capita che un signore è chiamato
da un tribunale a dire quali sono secondo lui i suoi diritti. A partire dal 400 è stato
individuato qualche caso, 5 in tutto che io sappia, 1 nel 400, 3 nel 500, 1 alla fine del
600 sotto il re sole ancora. In vari postacci sperduti in cui un signore locale chiamato
da un tribunale a dichiarare quali erano i suoi diritti e gli obblighi dei suoi contadini
ha detto mi pagano questo, mi pagano quello, l'agnello a Pasqua, il maiale a Natale, 10 soldi
quando comprano una terra, 20 soldi quando cambiano casa, 5 soldi quando si sposa la figlia
e questi 5 soldi quando si sposa la figlia è perché io avrei diritto di andarci a letto
la prima notte, ma i miei antenati hanno accettato di commutare questo diritto e quindi adesso
io mi accorgo, ma potrei sempre riprendere a pretendere questa cosa se i miei contadini
non stanno bravi. Quindi come vedete la fantasia diventa non proprio realtà ma una specie di
ipotesi del possibile. C'è 5 su centinaia di migliaia di signori vissuti in Europa che hanno
litigato così tanto con i loro contadini da andare a dirgli guarda che se non smettete di farmi
arrabbiare io tiro fuori lo ius primen octis. Forse verrebbe anche la pena di accennare a questa
cosa, siamo quasi alla fine ma 5 minuti li abbiamo ancora. Il matrimonio nell'Europa della fine del
medioevo e della prima età moderna non è una cosa tanto privata, anzi è una cosa molto pubblica e che
è anche al centro di molti conflitti che sono abbastanza accettati dalla gente anche se sono
conflitti e possono creare problemi. Vi faccio un esempio di conflitto. Si sposa la ragazza del
villaggio con uno di un altro paese, di un altro villaggio. Abbiamo già detto che al signore questo
scoccia e che quindi bisogna pagare. Ma la cosa dà fastidio anche agli altri ragazzi del villaggio.
È una delle nostre ed è venuto uno di quegli altri a prendersela e ce la porta via. È normale che i
ragazzi del villaggio quando una loro compagna si sposa e va a stare in un altro paese, quando il
corteo nuziale sta per uscire, gli fan trovare la strada sbarrata. La strada è sbarrata, i giovanotti
del villaggio sono tutti lì e dicono allo sposo se vuoi portarla via paga da bere e lo
sposo 99 volte su 100 abbozza, si sa, e paga da bere a tutti e allora gli tolgono la barriera
e lo fanno andare. Una volta su 100 lo sposo, è uno che ha già bevuto un po', si arrabbia,
si picchiano, ci scappa il morto. Il banchetto di nozze e il momento poi della prima notte di
nozze sono momenti anche quelli di questo tipo. Il banchetto vengono tutti. Nell'immaginazione
del romanziere Falcones il signore capita lì per caso, non sapeva che il contadino si sposava,
figuriamoci, lo sapevano tutti queste cose. E il signore era invitato di solito al banchetto
e come? Perché tenerselo buono è importante e anche a lui serve tenersi buoni i contadini
ricchi. Quindi ci va, gli battezzerà poi i figli, va al banchetto e ci tiene andare al
banchetto e sedersi al posto d'onore. Ogni tanto c'è anche qualche signore che litiga
con i contadini perché l'hanno invitato ma non gli è andato da bere abbastanza bene,
doveva bere meglio e lui ha il diritto di bere il vino migliore che c'è al banchetto,
non quello che danno agli ospiti di seconda categoria. E poi quando la sposa va finalmente
a letto con suo marito c'è un'infinità di rituali possibili. In generale tutti gli invitati
maschi preparano il marito e le donne preparano la moglie. Li svestono, li mettono in camicia
da notte, gli fanno un po' di scherzi, un po' di battute, un po' di oscenità e poi
finalmente li chiudono in camera. Ci sono signorie dove il signore dice sono io che ho il diritto
di accompagnare la sposa in camera perché il signore di questo villaggio sono io e si deve
vedere. In altre parole esiste tutto un contesto folclorico in cui intorno al matrimonio si possono
intrecciare, sì, degli obblighi, degli obblighi verso la collettività. Ed è in questo contesto
che se gli eruditi credono che in passato c'erano ius primen octis, ecco non ci vuole
molto perché cominci a crederci anche qualcuno sul serio. Dopodiché concludiamo. Lo ius primen octis
è una straordinaria fantasia che il medioevo ha creato, che è nata alla fine del medioevo
e a cui hanno creduto così tanto che c'era quasi il rischio che qualcuno volesse metterlo
in pratica davvero, anche se non risulta che sia mai successo davvero. In realtà è una
fantasia, non è mai esistito. Questo vuol dire che il signore ogni tanto non andava a letto
con la ragazza del villaggio, no, non vuol dire questo, il signore andava a letto con
la ragazza del villaggio, con le buone e con le cattive. Queste sono cose che succedono
in ogni società diseguale, ma è una differenza immensa, una società in cui capita che il
ricco ne approfitta e va a letto con la ragazza povera e immaginare invece, che è una vera
follia, una società dove questo sia un diritto a cui tutti si devono rassegnare perché lo dice
la legge. Che il signore andasse a letto con le ragazze del villaggio è come dire
che nell'ottocento il padrone della Filanda o suo figlio ogni tanto andava a letto con
l'operaia. È come se il padrone della Filanda andava a letto ogni tanto con l'operaia. C'erano
mille motivi per cui questo poteva succedere, ma ovviamente nessuno si sarebbe sognato di
dire che era un diritto. Parlarne come di una legge significa voler inventare un passato.
E allora io chiuderei con un passo che io trovo straordinario, che parla proprio dell'invenzione
del passato. È tratto dal romanzo di Orwell, 1984. Nel romanzo di Orwell a un certo punto
si parla di come sotto il regime del grande fratello veniva reinventato per il popolo il
passato. Nel passato, si insegna al popolo, c'erano delle creature malvagie, chiamate i
capitalisti. E i capitalisti opprimevano il popolo in tutti i modi, con ogni sorta di abusi
e di soprusi. Cito testualmente. C'era anche una cosa chiamata lo ius prime noctis, che probabilmente
non sarebbe da menzionare nei libri di scuola per bambini. Era la legge secondo la quale
ogni capitalista aveva il diritto di andare a letto con ogni donna che lavorava nelle sue
fabbriche. Ecco, io questo lo trovo fantastico perché per l'appunto Orwell ha individuato
esattamente il meccanismo. Ciò che può succedere nella realtà ed è una violenza ed è un effetto
dei rapporti sociali, si immagina che fosse una legge. Perché immaginare una società
in cui una cosa del genere possa essere una legge significa immaginare una società veramente
aliena, totalmente barbara rispetto ai nostri valori. E quindi appunto, quando noi vogliamo
riscrivere il passato e immaginarcelo ed essere contenti che noi viviamo in un mondo
tanto migliore rispetto al passato, lo ius prime noctis è perfetto per arredare questo
passato. Grazie.
Grazie.